actualizamos las noticias económicas con
Juan Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo saludo
nuevamente acá estamos otra vez y con
una noticia bien interesante sobre el
ranking de las 10 ciudades más caras de
Estados Unidos y bueno puede haber quien
le interesa entre nuestros televidentes
Así que Claro que sí de las máscaras
pero también de las más baratas y esas
como la parte que nos importa no la
clasificación la hizo Smart asset que es
bastante particular porque muestra
Cuánto dinero debes ganar en cada ciudad
para sentir que estás ganando 100 mil
dólares una suma emblemática en
bienestar de Estados Unidos y una zumba
que también pues se ve anual no vamos a
ver el siguiente gráfico porque pues ahí
están las ciudades y tenemos entonces
las de las 10 ciudades no ocupó el
primer lugar Nueva York que es una
sorpresa de este ranking Pero entonces
por ejemplo en Nueva York se necesita
ganar 312 mil dólares al año para sentir
que estás ganando o que tienes en dinero
real 100.000 dólares entonces ahí están
toda la lista por ejemplo la capital
está en el lugar número 7 que comparte
el mismo ingreso con los ángeles y Long
Beach todos con 245 mil dólares al año
para el caso de las más baratas veamos
por ejemplo el caso de El Paso esta
ciudad
84.966 dólares al año si una persona
tiene ese ingreso de sentiría o
percibiría que está ganando 100 mil
dólares al año lo que es pues una en
este caso pues una noticia positiva y
que todo esto depende de los impuestos
pero también de la inflación del costo
de vida de cada ciudad no no Pues fíjese
que en las que están en rojo están
prácticamente nuestros corresponsales
estadounidenses que después de esto son
prácticamente unos Héroes no es
básicamente después de ese ranking Así
es vamos a cambiar de tema las potencias
europeas siguen buscando estrategias
para dejar de depender económicamente de
China y uno de esos más recientes
esfuerzos parece que será la
consolidación de un acuerdo entre la
Unión Europea e Indonesia o por lo menos
así lo adelantó el canciller de Alemania
la principal economía de Europa según
olace el mismo el mismo presionará al
bloque de los 27 para que se haga reales
y acuerdo con Indonesia que es uno de
los países más poblados del sudeste
asiático escuchemos Cuál es la cifra que
más le llama la atención a Berlín de
este acuerdo
de repente esto crearía una área
económica común con más de 700 millones
de personas Indonesia y la comisión
europea han estado negociando esto desde
2016 me comprometo a garantizar que
finalmente lleguemos a este acuerdo
sobre la línea de meta y después de lo
que usted acaba de decir señor
presidente estoy seguro de que también
podemos tener éxito juntos
miren nos adentramos en nuestra región
está de visita el ministro de exteriores
de Rusia en América Latina va a visitar
los países más estratégicos con los que
tiene relación cuéntenos usted Juan
Pablo Ángela una visita que ya comenzó
con la primera economía de latinoamérica
que es Brasil pero que como lo dice
Usted también se extenderá por Venezuela
Nicaragua y Cuba países aliados de la
región Pues de Rusia en un comunicado
este lunes la portavoz de exteriores
María sarajoa aseguró abro comillas para
nosotros América Latina es una región
amistosa uno de los centros de formación
del mundo multipolar con la que Rusia
Procura mantener un diálogo Dinámico y
desarrollar la cooperación constructiva
libre de cualquier imposición foránea
cierro comillas y ese con la visita de
Moscú se espera también beneficios
mutuos en materia de Educación cultura
comercio y economía Rusia es el
principal proveedor de fertilizantes de
Brasil y depende de sus compradores para
desarrollar la agroindustria con la que
se ha convertido en una de las potencias
alimentarias del mundo y pues de esto
nos dimos cuenta con la guerra en
Ucrania y pues el bloqueo de varios
puertos previo al viaje el canciller
ruso resaltó que a pesar de las
sanciones y presiones políticas del
bloque occidental liderado por Estados
Unidos las exportaciones de Rusia a la
región se incrementaron en un 3,8% de
2022 los suministros de fertilizantes y
productos derivados del petróleo también
aumentaron mientras los envíos de trigo
crecieron un 48,8% es decir casi la
mitad de ese trigo Pues llega acá a esta
región
incorporada por B por ser Perú está
Generalmente entre los titulares no y
algo aún más particular son los cambios
en su economía pese a las diversas
crisis políticas sé que está pasando en
este momento allí y Ángel al año pasado
hablábamos de cómo resistía la economía
de allá pero ahora Estamos hablando de
un escenario que no es positivo para el
país andino porque su economía cayó un
0,63% en febrero siendo este el segundo
retroceso consecutivo el dato Negativo
si le atribuye a las protestas sociales
de las en las principales ciudades luego
de las tensiones políticas del país y
pues el masivo rechazo a la presidenta
Dina boluarte la disminución del
producto interno bruto se sintió en
cinco sectores económicos el
agropecuario el de manufactura el de
construcción el de telecomunicaciones y
El Financiero Mientras tanto el
Ministerio de economía y finanzas dijo
que espera que su pib crezca a partir de
marzo y ya veremos qué pasará con este
país aprovechemos y hablemos de los
indicadores y le parece miremos Entonces
los mercados de la jornada las bolsas
ejércitos reportaron ganancias motivadas
por el buen escenario bursátil en
Estados y confiando en que la reserva
Federal no continúe su camino al alza
con los tipos de interés pero nos
daremos cuenta de esto por allá en mayo
las bolsas europeas siguen operando en
terreno mixto entre los indicadores de
Frankfurt de Alemania Londres y París
solo el de la capital británica Estaba
reportando ganancias hasta el último
momento Juan Pablo y por si se lo
perdieron nuestros televidentes en el
primer bloque la cifra del día
775 millones de dólares ese eso es lo
que le costó a la compañía japonesa sega
la compra de la empresa finlandesa Rubio
entertainment la fabricante de Angry
Birds rovio dijo que Angry Birds fue el
primer juego móvil que se descargó mil
millones de veces y recordemos que la
marca también ha producido dos películas
sobre este juego Le invito a que
descargue la aplicación No pues gracias
y viene mañana mañana venimos con más de
economía Pues acá lo espero Gracias Juan
Pablo acá estaremos